let's play a game imagine a world where
china and america are at war but america
loses and china becomes the world's
uncontested superpower and as punishment
china breaks up the united states
california becomes its own country
florida and texas become their own
countries and even new york home of the
most american city ever is taken away
stripped from america and becomes its
own country
america as you know it is no more and as
an american that would break your heart
but let's take it a step further not
only have the most american states
become not american anymore but china
comes in and installs pro-chinese
pro-communist government in california
new york and florida maybe even canada
and mexico as well one could even call
these new heads of state public
governments that only answered to
beijing but it doesn't stop there
suddenly china gets california to join a
military alliance with china putting the
chinese military and chinese nukes at
the front door of america
now if any conflict occurs between
america and california may be a border
dispute an accidental shoot down of an
aircraft etc the full force of china
will rain down upon america in an
instance now i bet that that will make
you feel a little uneasy and a little
uncomfortable but let's keep going then
just a few years later china maybe gets
canada to join that military alliance
too then florida a few years after that
and then finally they're welcoming new
york into the alliance with open arms
this is the final straw china has
already taken so much away from america
and now they have to come after new york
too the crown jewel of what was once
america the essence of america where all
our culture and movies are centered
around that's just a few hours away from
washington dc sure new yorkers have a
slightly different accent than americans
but we're practically the same new york
falling to the chinese would be the red
line in this hypothetical america
invading new york right now would
actually be less risky than waiting for
them to join china's military lines we
can liberate the new yorkers now and
welcome them back into the states
without the full force of the chinese
military but if we wait for them to join
china's military alliance all would be
lost
ukraine is to russia what new york is to
america
america created vladimir putin and
ukraine is our fault but to understand
why we have to take a trip back in time
to the fall of the soviet union
[Music]
after six and a half years in power
mikhail gorbachev confirmed
[Music]
december 1991 in the dead of winter
three men met in a forest on the border
of belarus and poland these three men
were pretty high ranking the president
of ukraine the president of belarus and
the president of russia boris yeltsin
and at the stroke of a pen these three
men decided to part ways to disband the
soviet union and in an instance the
soviet union was no more and ukraine
belarus and russia became their own
independent countries each of these
three men had their own reasoning for
party ways but for the president of
russia yeltsin his reasoning was clear
see yeltsin was the president of russia
proper not the soviet union that honor
went to mikhail gorbachev the leader of
the soviet union russia was the biggest
entity within the soviet union but
yeltsin was still number two to
gorbachev that meant if yeltsin got rid
of the soviet union gorbachev would be
no more and yeltsin would be number one
so that's what he did the cold war ended
the constant threat of nuclear war was
over and the military alliance of soviet
countries called the warsaw pact was no
more and now america was faced with a
decision what do we do with this new
country called russia do we still treat
them like the enemy do we punish them
like we did with germany after world war
ii or do we wipe the slate clean and
start anew
yeltsin wanted the latter he wanted to
make amends with the americans so he
went to america to offer peace
yeltsin came to the united states and he
addressed a joint session of congress
and he said the people of russia are
offering their hand to the people of the
united states in friendship to build a
better world
a world without war a world without
peace and this was exactly what the vast
majority of russians wanted and i would
even say that today
the vast majority of russians would like
to have if not a friendship with the
united states at least a partnership
there's no doubt to my mind that that's
the case
so the u.s could have approached russia
one of two ways
the united states could have picked two
ways of treating russia
one was to say let's treat russia like
we did our enemies after world war ii
germany
italy
and as some of the countries that were
occupied
such as france or were not occupied such
as uk but were really badly hurt let's
find a way to see to it that in those
countries nazis fascists do not come
back and communists do not come to power
and may i remind you that in those days
the communist party of france
and the communist party of italy were
very very powerful and that plan turned
out
was called later the marshall plan which
was
basically a financial idea to spend a
lot of money but in a very precise way
to develop certain things and not to
allow others to develop now that could
be the policy to adopt visiting russia
see to it that democracy begins to
develop in that country and let me say
just for the record russia never in its
entire thousand years
never had democracy
completely absent so it wasn't like
something that once upon a time russians
had and then they lost but they knew
what it was they didn't know what it was
so
let's spend money on getting democracy
moving in russia and seeing to it that
the communists do not get back and that
could have been one approach
the other approach was to say for 40
years you held a nuclear bomb over our
heads
you lost the cold war and you're going
to pay for it you're going to be
punished
for what you did
and there were people who
supported one view and people who
supported the other in this country can
you guess which route america decided to
take instead of trying to make things
work america decided it would never let
another country challenge it ever again
american supremacy was the only goal
basically that view was the one that was
accepted it was the one that would
accept it and the attitude towards
russia was pretty much
you're no longer a superpower you are a
second-rate country
just keep quiet
please
and this decision this attitude changed
this fork in the road was what would
eventually lead to the crisis in ukraine
today
[Music]
as punishment for ukraine the banks that
you trust for your own money have frozen
the accounts of people even suspected of
being tied to russia
even swiss banks that banked for germans
in world war ii froze russian assets the
message is clear your fia is not safe
from governments whatsoever that is the
problem crypto solves and one great
crypto startup is toon.fm tunefm is the
web 3 of spotify that's actually live
and working it already has artists like
beyonce on there and basically when the
music gets played the artist gets paid
immediately for every second of
streaming and it's much more than what
an artist can earn on spotify like
upwards of 10x more
the reason this is possible is because
it's running their native jam token
which is based on something called
hedera hashgraph an enterprise level
distributed ledger technology owned by
google ibm boeing and much more this
tech is already working for these giant
companies and it actually allows for
fast and cheap micro transactions unlike
fia or bitcoin or any other coin project
you see out there that's based on an
ethereum erc protocol this allows
artists to get paid right away and it
even allows for you the listener to get
paid just by listening to music on tune
fm
that means if you help discover new
music or you help curate music on tune
fm you get paid if this sounds at all
interesting to you tune fm is giving you
guys 100 jam coins for free to give it a
listen right now when you go to tune.fm
with the link below and sign up you have
nothing to lose by giving it a try and
you'll also be helping improve the music
industry so go to tune.fm with the link
below to claim your free 100 jam coins
right now thanks to tune fm for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
back when the berlin wall was still
standing the soviet leader gorbachev and
the u.s came to an agreement to tear
down the berlin wall and reunify germany
but on one sole condition nato was not
to move an inch eastward towards russia
this was a big deal and a big promise
you see nato is a military alliance by
western powers to keep europe safe from
the threat of the soviet union during
the cold war and america basically runs
nato because the us is the biggest and
strongest player in it nato's entire
existence is based around russia being
the sole enemy nato expanding into
eastern europe would be the equivalent
of china getting countries like canada
or mexico to join a military alliance
with them it directly threatens america
so that's why russia's sole condition
was that nato not expand especially with
post-soviet countries like ukraine
poland the czech republic and hungary
and for the next 10 years nato and the
u.s kept their promise nato stayed put
and russia kept its notes out of their
business but then president bill clinton
entered his second term and things
started getting ugly somewhere along the
line the u.s started thinking who is
russia to tell us what we can or can't
do we won the war and it didn't help
that at the same moment poland the czech
republic and hungary were desperately
trying to join nato you see nato wasn't
just for protecting europe against the
soviets anymore being a member also gave
you access to more trade sharing of
resources and foreign aid for its less
fortunate members something poland the
czech republic and hungary wanted to get
in on and that got the u.s thinking why
not just let them join nato russia is
unpredictable sure they're playing nice
now but what happens when we disagree
with them in the future it would be nice
to have a few bases and troops close
enough to make a difference if it comes
to it so in the late 90s a promise was
broken the only promise russia cared
about and poland the czech republic in
hungary were admitted into nato he
called him up and he asked him what did
he think
about this decision to enlarge nato let
me quote this is may 2nd 1998 i think it
is the beginning
of a new cold war
said mr kennen yeltsin was very ugly
he made a speech he said and of course
this is very yeltsin like he said we're
not haiti
you can't treat us like haiti
we're a great country
we have
a great past
and russia will come back
russia will come back he was really
really
angry
12 days later nato forces started
bombing yugoslavia a country that wasn't
part of the soviet union but was always
under heavy soviet influence yugoslavia
is in russia's backyard nato didn't have
un permission and they didn't give
russia any warning they just decided to
do it because they were nato
from when gorbachev came to power march
1985 to 2007
when putin has been in power for seven
years that's 22 years
i ask you to find a single thing in
foreign or domestic policies
done by
the soviet union wealth that existed and
then russia proper that might in any way
anger irk disappoint the united states
let me answer that today nothing
not one thing during that period now
what did russia get as a result of that
first
the enlargement of nato so that was
number one
then the bombing of yugoslavia that was
done by nato and nato is after all
dependent mostly on the united states
let's face it right
uh the u.n did not condone this
so the bombing of yugoslavia that's uh
from march 24 99 to june 10th
then uh
and recognition of kosovo though it had
been part of serbia for centuries and
there were people in russia who said
you're letting
the jinn out of the bottle because if
you do this then there are other
countries that will do the same
and russia did the same this was the
turning points russia had tried playing
by the rurals but it was clear that the
americans didn't take them seriously and
that the west couldn't be trusted
just one year after the yugoslavia
bombings vladimir putin became president
and a new era of russian foreign policy
dons
children ukrainian elder people
ukrainian ladies who are killed directly
by putin and this is
you mr putin is a killer is a maniac the
west likes to point the finger at pune
for being the aggressor the madman adolf
hitler reincarnated but the thing is
before the mid-2000s there was no
evidence poon ever really hated the us
back when he was still deputy mayor of
st petersburg he was even known for
helping us businesses settle contract
disputes with russians he was fascinated
with the ex-secretary of state henry
kissinger and there's no record of any
of the anti-american stuff he's saying
now although he was in the kgb and back
in the early 2000s putin did everything
he could to give america the benefit of
the doubts as soon as poon was elected
he asked to join nato 2000 the year 2000
mr putin is
not elected although elected to the
presidency
and one of the first things he does is
to ask for russia to become a member of
nato
why
not be a member of nato nato was created
to defend
europe and perhaps not only europe
from soviet aggression
from a country that you couldn't predict
there is no more soviet union and there
is no more warsaw pact
why can't we
create an organization where we're part
of it said mr putin and act together to
protect some kind of aggression he was
told go take a walk basically what about
some kind of partnership or becoming
part of the european union
and he said they were no you know you're
too big your country's too big you can't
then when 9 11 happened he offered his
country's expertise in afghanistan to
help fight the war on terror
as soon as 9 11 happens
calls up bush jr w and offers his help
and yes and does help in afghanistan
and if you want to have your soldiers
your military people in in central asia
right on our borders be my guest and in
georgia absolutely so it's not just
words
you know we we want to fight terrorism
together
every attempt russia and putin made to
work with the us was met with scoff the
u.s broke its promises and putin had had
enough
and all the while russia was being
reminded that it's no longer really that
important the country
now one of the things you must keep in
mind is that much like the americans the
russians believe that they have a
mission that their country was selected
by destiny so the sense of losing this
aura
of greatness of being told we don't care
about you
the uh the reaction of the average
russian to that was one of
you're you're insulting me you're not
you don't respect me
in 2007
in munich
speaking to the 20 the group of 20 in
munich putin says this
this is february 10th i think it is
obvious that nato expansion does not
have any relation with the modernization
of the alliance itself or with ensuring
security in europe on the contrary it
represents a serious provocation that
reduces the level of mutual trust
and we have the right to ask against
whom is this expansion intended
and what happened to the assurance of
our western partners made after the
dissolution of the warsaw pact where are
those declarations today no one even
remembers them but i will allow myself
to remind this audience what was said
i would like to quote the speech of
general secretary mr werner of brussels
on may 17 1990 he said at the time quote
the fact that we are not ready to place
a nato army outside
of german territory gives the soviet
union a firm security guarantee where
are these guarantees and do you know
what the answer was
the answer was yes but that was
guarantees given to the soviet union
and you're russia
well what kind of a reaction would you
expect
last year i think it was
making a foreign policy speech putin
said
our mistake was that we trusted you too
much and your mistake was that you tried
to take advantage of that
the west did not take russia's warning
seriously
just a year after poon made his warning
abundantly clear america and nato takes
it a step further
nato's bucharest summit a declaration is
issued which says nato welcomes
ukraine's and georgia's euro-atlantic
aspirations for membership in nato that
these countries will become members of
nato so putin himself said georgia and
ukraine becoming part of nato is a
direct threat to russia
and almost immediately putin invades
georgia using pretty much the exact same
playbook he's using today in ukraine
russia recognized two pro-russian
separatist provinces in georgia just
like it did in ukraine and used that as
an excuse to move troops in and then
launch a full-scale invasion of georgia
marking the first european war of the
21st century
you all remember that there was a war
between russia and georgia in august
2008 that war was a consequence of this
because the georgians thought we were
sending them a signal that they could
get uppity with the russians and we
would back them because they were going
to become part of nato that's not what
happened and you know what happened the
russians clobbered the georgians and
georgia is in deep trouble today because
it thought it it could become part of
nato
the only difference between ukraine and
georgia is that there was hardly any
public outcry compared to today
and if you follow the money there's a
very specific reason for that which we
may go over in the future video very
soon so make sure you subscribe
luckily for ukraine they had a
pro-russian president at the time and
joining nato wasn't a big possibility
but just five years later that was all
about to change
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
back in november 2013 the pro-russian
president of ukraine yanukovych was
weighing his options for the country's
future he could accept a deal from the
eu and leave russia in the dust or he
could take vladimir putin's deal for a
15 billion loan and keep their
relationship going
it all starts in november of 2013 at
that point yanukovych president
yanukovych who's the head of ukraine is
negotiating with the eu
to form an association agreement that
brings the eu
and ukraine much closer together it's a
step in the direction of incorporating
ukraine into the european union or to
put it in slightly different terms
incorporating ukraine into the west
the russians make it clear that this is
unacceptable
russians are willing to do a deal that
involves the eu russia the imf and
ukraine but the idea that ukraine is
going to do a deal exclusively with the
eu and the russians are going to be left
out in the cold it's not something that
putin is willing to countenance he puts
significant pressure on the ukrainians
he offers them a terrific deal and as
you can imagine the eu is not offering
ukraine a particularly good deal because
you know how much corruption there is in
ukraine and the eu wants ukraine to
eliminate that corruption which the
ukrainians really don't want to do so
what putin does is not only make it
clear that that deal is not going to
happen but he often just offers a
sweetheart deal of his own so yanukovych
on november 21st says no to the eu
yanukovych canceled the eu deal and
suddenly ukraine erupts into pro-western
protests
the ukrainian government reacts harshly
to the protests and a month into it we
had the first two deaths in the protests
[Music]
two protesters have reportedly been
killed in the armrest in kiev
in the february 18th
through february 20th time period
lots of people die
it's really messy
and what happens is with a number of
european foreign ministers the german
foreign minister french foreign minister
they fly to kiev and a deal is worked
out to have elections that will in
effect remove yanukovych from power but
the protesters refuse to accept the deal
and there are significant fascist
elements among the protesters who were
armed right
there's killing on the maidan
and as a result yanukovych flees for his
life to russia and this all happens on
february 22nd
in other words a coup just took place in
russia's crown jewel the equivalent of a
pro-china coup taking place in new york
and to the russians the instigators of
this coup was clearer it was the west
and the thing is knowing america's track
record of creating funding and
instigating coups they're probably right
in ukraine the conversation was deferred
they had this basically pro-russian
democratically elected president
yukonovich who was deposed in a coup in
2014 a coup that was supported by our
state department and probably the cia
okay immediately russia invades the
ukrainian peninsula of cremia putin sees
crimea not a year later not months later
days later the reason why he was able to
seize it so quickly is the russians
actually have
a naval base there at sevastopol okay
the area is leased from ukraine but they
have a naval base there it allows them
to control the black sea so
the the russian thinking on this if you
believe it goes that listen we're about
to have a pro-western ruler come into
ukraine installed by what an american
backed coup and now we're going to lose
our main naval base in the black sea and
it could be replaced with a nato base
there's no way that's happening so they
moved to seize crimea and then after
that they started backing russian
separatists in the donbass and the civil
war began okay so that basically is
what's been leading up to this
after the invasion of crimea in 2014
things stayed tense after a military
buildup on the border of ukraine russia
releases its final warning in writing to
america and nato which included banning
ukraine from entering nato
and we could talk about whether it's a
pretext in a second but from the russian
perspective they said that listen and
putin gave a speech like this if ukraine
joins nato because of article 5 the next
time we have a border dispute which is
all the time right we could end up
getting drawn into a war three with you
guys and so there is no way we're going
to allow ukraine to be part of nato and
so they propose they basically by
december had given an ultimatum to the
state department what was our response
to that well the u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken came out and basically
told russia to go do something to
himself that it can't anatomically do
from our perspective i can't be more
clear
nato's door
is open remains open and that is our
commitment the west once again did not
take russia's threat seriously and a
month later putin declares war on
ukraine
is it right no but when everyone is
religiously painting one man as evil
there's usually another side to the
story that you're not hearing i do think
there's something different when it goes
from a large majority having one way to
um it being almost unanimous where
and because things are never unanimous
when so when when people are unanimously
on one side that tells you not that
they've all figured out the truth but
that they're in a sort of totalitarian
place that they're in a one-party state
where they're not allowed to have
dissenting views
i've actually been to ukraine just a few
months ago back in august kiev
specifically so when i saw them invade
it was like very heartbreaking because
i've interacted with these people and
most of them are just trying to get by
but again i wanted to tell the other
side of the story because you're not
really hearing that anywhere right now
and i've talked to a lot of russian
people that think putin is completely
insane so more russian videos are coming
going over other stuff people aren't
talking about right now so make sure you
subscribe so you don't miss out and you
can also donate to ukraine with the
button below yeah that's gonna wrap it
up stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next one
wow
you